my father taught me many great gifts how
to be cool how to get the ladies how to
build the wall but most of all how to
run a real [ __ ] nice pimp studio
thanks dad
I may have failed in my previous
syndaver deborah's [ __ ] you but this
time I'm going all out I am creating a
new company holy [ __ ] what is Oh my new
company v3 big bouncy boobies
Nikki you look like you're from tumblr I
despise you I hate your guts but
business is business and you're hired
Nikki all right who's got the biggest
titties watches so it get the [ __ ] up
get the [ __ ] out so eight Keanu you got
that ass but get that
well [ __ ] do you take before we're
called a big teddy
teres belly you're in yeah you better be
you don't perform you're out what you
can what why did no one tell me you
could just hold down the button you just
have to hold down the button I've been
clicking like a gazillion times Jesus
Christ thanks for telling me thank you
so much okay we got Lyle on e she's
Asian
flat-chest not on it why do you show up
even get up all right Zoe Zoe we had
this talk before I'm hiring Tiffany
cause she's my main girl
my main booth after might see it of
course it's time to hire another one
okay we got Lillian
she's teen tattoos [ __ ] up [ __ ] off
Lillian why is it so hard
Iko Asian glasses yeah I did [ __ ]
you're dead to me you're dead to me why
does she have so many facts Oh glasses
oh they're into glasses
big teenage glasses company are we
hiring her
you better get some implants all right
what's her cup size be that where are
the big breasted women
Candace finally yes from the gods
Candace you're in what god damn it why
is it so expensive to run this business
you guys aren't making me money you're
making me [ __ ] [ __ ] all the worth
money what the [ __ ]
this pimpest this is gonna be the end of
me what's next is trying to not get me
bankrupt hey we're gonna promo glasses
I love nerd girls yeah you're into that
[ __ ] yeah bet you are you [ __ ] perv
gimme glasses glasses or tits come on go
Isis or tit [ __ ] sake you're all
useless one dollar per hour Keanu you're
in look how much money I [ __ ] own
well paper at the day spa go have a day
at the spa well I'm collecting away
now listen so much [ __ ] money involved
I gotta pay the bill somehow I'm sorry
Candace we're not making the money we
need go to the hotel please
please and don't contract any STDs
please thank God Candace hepatitis
Candace Candace is caught happy today I
am so disappointed in you Candace
Tiffany one dollar an hour
Tiffany you're in you're in now buy me
shoes my big breasted glasses girls are
so [ __ ] high I mean I'm so good
Candace run out of steroids Candace is
back in business what she still has
hepatitis what the [ __ ] is wrong with
your hepatitis how do you wait oh my god
Zoe how many times are you trying how
many [ __ ] times I gotta tell yours
only get the [ __ ] out and stop wasting
my time you got zero potential zero hey
Tiffany
where this blood plug will you go
shopping
but plug right Zoey you want him working
this business so hard
here take this butt plug buy me some
cigarettes [ __ ] up huge tits and glasses
that's what they want and that's what we
provide what how did you get an STD you
wear a condom no oh god I didn't give it
a condom she got chlamydia now [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] kill me why why does this
happen
[ __ ] got this [ __ ] I got this [ __ ]
out of the [ __ ] bag I was born to do
this [ __ ] I breathe to do the [ __ ] I'm
left finish it I'm gonna have to hire my
last car of Marlena Gigi's ferry but she
said naturally but ain't nothing natural
about that girl oh my god that money big
breasted glasses best idea I ever had
finally finally I'm ruling the pimpest
miss big breasted glasses was all I ever
needed my mom would be so proud of me
she looked at me right now the way I
handled women with such dignity and
respect even tumblr would approve of
this video to the pimping [ __ ] that's
me [ __ ] what happen stop
yes I finally beat the game finally I
did it yeah I am so happy about that big
breast of glasses that's how it's done
y'all play a haters can [ __ ] up that's
how it's done
alright well leave a like if you enjoyed
watching this video thank you so much
for watching and as always do all my
hoes
call me is it hot in here
am i sweating alright let's get another
girl yeah we got Sarah she's got a thick
ass uh